وفي هذا الخبر قبل سنوات فقط كانت شركات
التواصل الاجتماعي تشبه الحلم والان في 20
22 الجميع خسر تقريبا وسقط الحلم ومعها
سقطت الثقاب فاذا تحدثنا بدايه في
التفاصيل منصات التواصل تحظى باقل قدر من
الثقه بين 12 قطاعا عالميا هذا بحسب
استطلاع اجرته وكاله الاستشارات التسويقيه
لدى من على 15,000 مشارك في 15 سوقا
عالميا وبشكل العام لم تتعدى الثقه في تلك
منصات نسبه 47% وحتى من حيث التجربه
اليوميه للمستخدم العادي انخفضت الثقه
الاجماليه في جميع المنصات عن ما كانت في
العام الماضي فمثلا المستخدم الامريكي قضى
هذا العام وقتا اقل اعلى المنصات
الاجتماعيه وفقا لبحث اجرته انسايد
الانتاج الجنس ومن حيث ترتيب احتفظ فيسبوك
بمرتبته الاخيره بين المنصات الاخرى كما
هو الحال في العام الماضي حيث لا يزال
موصوما بحمايته للمعلومات المضلله على كل
حال لم يسمعها المزيد من الارقام اليك
67000 عامل في قطاع التكنولوجيا الامريكي
تم الاستغناء عن خدماتهم خلال العام
الجارحه حتى منتصف نوفمبر واللوم على
عمليه التوظيف المكثفه خلال الوباء بخلاف
التضخم وارتفاع اسعار الفائده واليكم
المزيد من الارقام نحو 50% من القوى
العامله لتويتر تم تسريحهم بعد ايام من
اتمام الى الناس صفقه استحواذ عالم منصه
التغريدات احد عشر الف موظف او نحو 13% هو
عدد الموظفين الذين كانوا متى الاستغناء
عنهم في جميع انحاء العالم وهي اول عمليه
تسريح جماعي في تاريخ الشركه 10,000 موظفه
امازون تسريحهم في حسابي تقارير صادره عن
عده صحف ومئت موظف من شركه اوريكل نحو الف
موظف هو عدد الموظفين الذين استغنت عنهم
مايكروسوفت في جميع انحاء العالم هو يقال
ان السبب هو تراجع مبيعات ويندوز لاجهزه
الكمبيوتر واخيرا تخطط انت لتصريح الاف
الموظفين مع انخفاض الشحنات الربع الثالث
من اجهزه الكمبيوتر خلال العام بدخل 15%
مقارنه بالعمل الماضي
[موسيقى]